what is it like to get a call from
Steven Spielberg at first I was nervous
I thought I was in trouble I've made a
lot of bad jokes over the years probably
some that he would find offensive I
would imagine he thought he was throwing
you out of Hollywood yeah maybe I was
just getting kicked out that's what
happens that's what happens Gilbert
calls he's like you're out and he wanted
me to play Someone inspired by uh his
uncle benny I didn't know how he was
gonna direct oh so the first day we
start shooting and we do a take and I'm
like you know I go back to where he's
standing and I'm like I'm looking for
feedback and he is just sobbing
uncontrollably and I thought oh no I'm
so bad he's crying his whole thing's a
disaster and he's gonna fire me right
now and he's gonna say I made him yeah
but no it was it's such a deeply
personal movie that he cried a lot
actually when the scenes were happening
you would go back and he would be
weeping and it and it and it felt I
never thought it would feel great to
make Steven Spielberg cry all the time
wow but it did it felt wonderful I'd
make him cry right now if I could